All right, now we are going to talk about introductions, meeting new people.
One of the first things that you want to make sure happens in an introduction,...
...and we're going to talk about several things that are real important to introductions,...
...but one of the most important,...
...we've been talking about it, is smiling.
When you are introduced to people or even when you introduce people,...
...you want to make sure and smile.
You know, you might be nervous.
You might be a little uncomfortable,...
...but again smile because what this shows is that you are open,...
...that you are positive,...
...that you are approachable,...
...that you are sincere.
It shows off lots and lots of positive qualities about you...
...that will make the person that's meeting you feel good about you,...
...and feel comfortable with you rather than if you didn't smile at all.
If you don't smile when you're meeting new people,...
...that gives very negative information,...
...so make sure, when you are meeting people for the first time, that you smile.